Master Wayne well Imaging is showing me  two dozen hostiles on the third floor  why don't I drop you off on the second  I'm getting slow in my old age effort  even you got too old to die young not a  lack of trying  he has the power to wipe out the entire  human race and we believe there's even a  1% chance that he is our enemy we have  to take it as an absolute sir  the greatest gladiator match in the  history of the world  God versus man  day versus night you're psychotic it's a  three syllable word for any thought too  big for little minds  but now if you wouldn't like you  I don't think you've ever known a woman  like me  the oldest line America  but power can be innocent  you